yeah welcome to this video playing black
against Alec 805 from the europe's no no
this one not be six from the US and i
come on let's let's play the accelerated
dragon for once and i don't think i
played this on video yet i am have
played plate this years ago gap of
course the verrat same here this one
roxy binders the the main theoretical
issue with this opening ok go for the
google needs a sister with taking on
deform yeah this is a recent idea
pushing the a pawn to a foreign Queen 85
it's not them not great for black hairy
not like you you can hope for from much
fun but it's a it's a good way to gain
some space on the queenside and maybe
get some play against the sea for porn
there should be six Roxy aid
yeah play rook c8 next unless he's doing
something out of the ordinary I have a
big edge on the clock this and this is
very rare okay my to d5 hmm yeah cannot
take the two as its Avila saying so I
probably need to take it the question is
how maybe with the bishop IAM to
increase the dark square control
so that I have 9725 with the pawn
already on a for the sum this gains a
bit and strength k has changed the coins
and now I was thinking 97 would be a
would be worth considering as a big
bonus the bee pollen saying that if he
needs to lose a booth then i'll donate
c5 and everything's fine the question is
is there some move like Roxy 7 yeah he
immediately goes for that okay I need to
go let's see five probably gathers thing
is just a I don't have any any big
choice yeah II 70 how does he protect
the beep on am i able to just take it
next move like rook is seven Bishop b2 I
don't think I'm that that bad this in
this kind of position if I exchange e74
be too
I can play maybe rupee one just yeah
just covering this I don't really fear
that it takes on on on c5 it takes b7
this just hands me that the dark squares
it's not done not a problem at all the
question is what about is seven
yeah rupee eight maybe rupee aid
intending also a 6m opening this up or
is this um some much much more active
move like f 54 is this completely eotech
yeah maybe maybe
he takes e7 I can take you form 20 I
didn't expect that at all
Kim
yeah let's exchange the active rook it
should should be beneficial
wow this guy is really slow Jeff yeah I
was just just seeing this I'm not sure
that it is so great down at the end to
have this Bishop against the night can
be tricky in the maroc see this Bishop
is notoriously bad I if I manage to home
to get my king 2d6 in this position the
question is question is am I am I really
much worse or is this something that I
can do even yeah cannot play a 3-yard
fortunately should I play b5 before it's
a good question b5 before if I just drop
the night bag I can try to just win the
porno
if i take t5 now at the end this b7
hanging him so this is this is a bit of
an annoyance hmm maybe i can i can play
some active Mesilla before we gave form
yeah
oopsie too it's my idea this is a bit of
a gamble IAM must admit but i thought i
would get this bag anyway and why not
try to okay it's I know he cannot play
the ship f3 and he's got this pawns on
light square so maybe i can i can get
some some syntactic in against against
the pawns yeah put this on dark squares
check yes now off to be form yeah the
upon the Acorn is my winner white
foreheads on time yeah handle i do i
really don't think this is so easy it
looks it looks great for what but maybe
it is not so easy check check yeah I am
maybe just take here only five this is
of course a position where I can just
try to to to hold on i mean it's it's
it's clear that i'm worse okay when
listen i'm not sure really it looks nice
but if you don't have anything anything
quickly then i'm going to g6 and and
block the de porn and do I simply have
the better not the better minor piece on
c5 this this is Bishop can can be active
later but it's not now and just just
here I think the worst is over how is he
going to make any big progress the
deponent can be can fall all the time
and again but a bit here
but I don't think I run much risk really
right here check he needs to be precise
I mean maybe it is still a draw but I
can maybe play play in Bishop f3 maybe
not the color and if you want to play
with 20 seconds on the clock yeah this
is finally and hence the tents again to
the game to me but I have ideas now the
main is to attack a two or two to
sacrifice on b3 mr. got no clear way to
to play against this can go to G 6f 76
then be 5 C 3 and so on it says always
tricky the computer is already giving me
more than one point wantage probably
winning already but he had to add an
excellent position around here of course
yeah thanks for watching